yeah welcome to a new video five minute
and he's inviting me OK when done let's
play a Sicilian again and I don't really
want want especially cough I don't know
that opening ready yeah I know it from
from the black side maybe let's play c3
transpose back into OC 3 Sicilian this
means i have to work it out entirely
over over the bottom Bishop chief form
hmm yeah probably i need to play this
but i think isn't this isn't this
supposed to be problematic for black
because of c4 and d5 let's let's play
this first and then c4 in d5 i think i
think this is right I had looked at this
from the black side years ago I think
this is the position where c4 and defy
this is tricky but ok it sir I only
looked at this briefly some years ago
when I was looking for some mum antidote
am against this is the CCU c3 Sicilian
for black eye it looks am it looks a
tricky for black where do you go now
yeah you need to do this probably but
this doesn't look too inviting very
quick on the on the farm question is
some what's the first move here just
castles you my plane Bishop d6 and 90210
g7
III am I maybe should be three first not
easy Dec lon it's a gap I need to
readjust back to five minutes time
control played mostly those rapid games
lately here 15 minute or even longer and
dumb does this mm-hmm okay yeah possible
what's more same thinking about Bishop 3
697 but he can you can play this of
course ok I want to get rid of the slide
yeah so now I've got this this past poll
on the default and maybe it's a good
idea to to do some supporting of this
pawn yarn I'd be five is this right at
the moment just try to two and take this
and play Bishop to f4 or Bishop g5 or
maybe we should be five with the idea
play 94 also not bad
oh come on I want to I want to simplify
the position about them I'm down on time
and really I thought I can just take
here and maybe this isn't such a big
deal it's possible grab the pawn get
just the depot now it just next report
don't really see what's the big idea
here I think I'm probably needs to go
rogue p8 now yeah so where where do you
go now I can go to c5 threatening 97 but
and I also like the idea to put this
piece on our five it's just just a
wonderful to square them and their five
it can be supported by by G for later it
always a text the H pole and it's also
really am annoying for blacks King this
piece yeah come on this is just just the
square for this piece um okay and what
now rookie three look do you want
something like this maybe don't want to
spend too much time it should be better
for wide them pretty much in any case
only thing I shouldn't do is blunder
some material of course them you should
play precisely but um can I can just
take this Bishop yeah that's it this
helps
this helps it was pretty terrible for
black anyway but so do you have for
getting this bishop i think i'm i'm not
sure i think this is a really
problematic line for black but the way
it turned out in the game it wasn't it
wasn't so bad or maybe i have some here
here here there's some better move this
is a possible of course but i can
somehow catch the king in the middle or
something but i don't i don't really see
how yeah i'm no expert on the c3
sicilian don't i don't know it dumb it
was still nice position a couple of
moves later alright thanks for watching